welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down
giselda the new Netflix show watches the
rise of the Godmother and I don't mean
your mom's a mate that she makes you
call Auntie still oh she's up in the ATI
like your uncle and the new show builds
off the back of the Naros Classics to
bring us a tale that often gets
overlooked based on the life of Griselda
blano we see as this black widow becomes
one of the kingpins of crime in Miami
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the show some of your
questions on what happened in real life
if you haven't seen the series then
there will be spoilers here and I highly
recommend that you check out if you
haven't checked it out without the way
huge thank you for clicking this now
let's get into
Griselda the first question you probably
have after the series that the big
question on your lips is did she really
call her son Michael Corone yep turns
out that's completely true with a
godmother naming her son after the
famous character in The God father
coron's grown up to style himself into
an internet personality and he's even
featured in the show the cartel crew now
where the series changes things is that
when grisela left prison two of her sons
were still alive in the show they have
it so it seems like they waited until
she was about to get released and
carried out the hit so it would be even
more painful in reality though the two
who died initially were killed years
before she got out of prison with a show
adding this in just to make some drama
his son Dixon died of unknown causes
years later though said it was
apparently due to his criminal activity
this is what made him realize that he
needed to get out and took a step
back from the drug trade you got your
beautiful grandchildren and you got your
beautiful granddaughter here and I'm
going to make sure that they don't have
to grow up how we did and live that life
now even though that's very tragic I'm
glad he hear the GU still alive and
doing well as I think one of the big
tragedies of the series is what happened
to Griselda and her family now he of
course had a very rough childhood and
one thing that the Show Skips over is
Galas in real life it's thought that
grisela carried a first kill when she
was just a mere 11 years old according
to the story she and her friends
kidnapped the son of a wealthy family
and this was in order to extort him for
ransom money the parents of course
didn't really take this seriously and th
gisala apparently gunned him down now
the Show Skips over all of this and when
we meet her she walks in like my wife
does when she needs a Wei this is on the
night that she mared her husband who has
just made her hook up with his brother
however what the show doesn't dive deep
into is that this is actually gala's
second husband the reason I call her
Black Widow before is that she's thought
to have killed all three of her husbands
Henry VII eat your bloody heart out but
I was really surprised that they skipped
over the first one his name was caroso
who was the father of her three eldest
boys it's believed that she had a hit
order on him during the 1970s which is
said to be over a business dispute as
for a second husband that's what we see
in the show and this is what makes blano
flee to Miami they kind of touch upon it
in the series and they talk about how
the pair sold in the 70s in real life
they moved in New York and it's from
here that they started to work however
the pair had to flee in order to avoid
persecution and this is where things
sort of start from it's in New York that
gisala apparently also met common or
well what the Bare Bones of her
character are in reality she's saw to be
an amalgamation of several people
grisela knew with her main inspiration
being common caban on top of this the
whole Brothers plot is a work of fiction
which has been implemented to make the
Escape seem more thrilling a lot of the
time they tend to add stuff for the
drama cuz let's be honest these people
weren't writing every single thought
that popped in their head and posting on
social media they also didn't have
camera Crews following them round at all
times so this stuff's been added in to
help beef them up his characters in
reality from what I can gather The
Killing was over Bravo siphoning
Millions from their money which he was
planning to keep for himself like the
show she ended up shooting him in a car
park but there was more than just the
man we see with him on top of this there
were five other cartel members who
Blanco W left dead in her awake at this
point she then moved to the US and as I
say the rest is history and that's kind
of what I love about the show as it
truly has her playing into her own
Twisted American Dream the idea of
selling dreams is Lay throughout the
series and it's what she initially says
that the drugs represent this will give
the wealthy Bard miamians is that is
that the other name well we'll give it
it'll give them a dream but beyond that
it's also how she recruits in her gang
she has the Overlook members of society
that she sells a dream that they can be
rich too she gives away the drugs for
free like how she gives a downtrodden
opportunities and it makes for something
that's a really thrilling watch plus you
got all that 80 Scarface as said that
was made famous in the Brian departa
film Scarface more like bra face he you
having that you suck now that is why
this channel is not doing as well as it
used to but another question that you
probably have is about the killings we
watch her taking down her Rivals one by
one and this is so she can become the
number one Crime Boss her man starts off
as her man in business but he gets taken
out which is something that happened in
real life known as the dayin M Massacre
that saw three of her Hitman riding to
the location with a van that said Happy
Time complete potty Supply stalking her
man they then went into the Crown Liquor
Store and carried out the hit at 2:30
p.m. there was also Papo as well who
gets killed at the airport with the real
life story being way worse apparently
his assassin carried World War II
bayonet and struck him in the stomach in
the middle of the airport there's a
documentary about this stuff called
Cocaine Cowboys which goes into the
grizzly tale behind it there was also
the sad tragic hit on Chucho which led
to his son's death in the back seat in
the buildup to it we see how paranoid
Griselda is and this is made worse by
her son's actions asking him to hide a
weapon Chucho Chu ends up hitting him
and in the end this causes a lot of
issues we see grisela then order the hit
and Ry pulls up in the car alongside him
Castro was sadly shot during this with
it later being one of the three murders
Blanco was arrested for in the show it
sees her relieved that riy missed but in
reality she wasn't said to have been
that kind she apparently celebrated his
son being killed because she saw that
his being a way to send a message really
sad and in the series it was clear she
started to suspect everyone around her
and at Dario's party she forces people
to do stuff at gunpoint con say because
of YouTube demonetization but this is
something had happened in real life
there were apparently several drug
fueled potties like this and we see how
drugs lead to the overdose of her friend
Mar this is what sends her on the run
and in terms of the series it's the
beginning of the end the show paints us
out as just being a freak accident but
in reality it's much much darker why
well that's because it's so Cal the
carry it out the murder after her debts
to her became too much gisala had a
habit of murdering those she owed money
to and she did this to wipe this slate
clean there's also no evidence of mod
dating Rafa which is something that was
added for some economic storytelling in
the series it sees her fleeing with her
family and after realizing Raa is coming
she calls the police this will mean that
she gets sent to jail rather than
meeting the Fate that he was just about
to bring this isn't the way it went down
though and she was caught due to good
oldfashioned police work this was
carried out by June Hawkins who is a
character that we Following the show
like gisala she's initially looked over
because of her gender and she acts as a
mirror that Chronicles her rise as
gisala becomes more important she does
too and she was one of the key officers
who helped take her down June in the DEA
carried out surveillance on her life and
they mapped out her movements which led
to her arrest she also ended up marrying
her P Ral who we meet throughout the
series Rafa was never actually in
America while this was going down and
therefore all of this scene it's a
complete work of fiction gisala was then
put on TR well and like we see in the
show Revy put a spanner in the
works
did like real life the show has him
turning in foran and this is in order to
avoid the death penalty that happened
along with the phone sex which
ultimately is what helped Griselda out
in real life he did it with two women
whereas in the show it was just the one
it damaged his credibility though as the
qy iners and thus his testimony couldn't
really be used it was all over the Miami
her
uh the state attorney's office was
embarrassed they had to fire several
people rivy basically did a great job at
botching the whole case by having phone
sex with the
secretaries eventually the decision was
made by the prosecution that the key
Witnesses had been compromised to the
point of it affecting his credibility on
the
stand it completely damaged his own case
too with him then being unable to make
deals later on he was sentenced to life
because of his initial actions but
further along in his life he was unable
to ever see release the phone call was
used as a way to show he was working
against the authorities and thus they
wouldn't be giving him any benefits at
all the show paints it out as being
something intentional and that's it's
clear the authorities took it that way
but whether that's the case we just
don't know Dario was also killed too
with having his murder carried out of a
custody of Michael now they do make up
the whole thing in the motel where he
saves her life from her ex-husband's
brother that isn't believed to have
happened and the actually got married in
Colombia before coming to the US Dario
then fled to Colombia which is where he
was shot and killed with Michael being
kidnapped in real life the Assassins
were dressed as police officers and
sadly this is what made him lower his
God now one thing we do know is that the
show says gisala served seven years
which is true from a certain point of
view the series hasn't being just
sentenced to this whereas in real life
she got 15 years she only served seven
though which was down to a heart attack
and was deported to Colombia on
compassionate release it's here in
Malene where she was gone down and this
event happened during 2012 the show ends
by showing text describing it with it's
saying that she was 69 years old now no
one has ever been tried for this murder
and there was no answer to who was
behind it all we know is that she was
with a pregnant daughter-in-law and that
someone rode by and shot her from a
motorbike ironically this is similar to
the hit she has selfie to Auto this
often being used as a method of
execution all in all it wraps up her
story with a Netflix Show pulling a lot
of punches grisela even had a dog named
Hitler which I'm guessing they could out
to make her seem more sympathetic once
you get behind it though it's hard to
deny how much of a bad person she was
and she probably never hit the thumbs up
or subscribed it saw that she murdered
upwards of 290 people with her regular
calling and hates so that she could stay
in power this is in order to stay with
Fabio and his family who themselves also
featured in knos definitely recommend
you check that out one of the actors
from this is in that too and I've
covered all those seasons on the channel
and we end with her sketching out lines
with a cigarette which is something that
she does throughout to manifest her
dream
all she wants though is to be back with
her kids however we know that's never
going to happen it's a side way to close
out the character and for the next part
of the video I want to talk about my
thoughts on the series as for this it
might not be as accurate as it could be
but I still really enjoyed what they
brought to the show there's so much
going on here and so many well-crafted
arcs that it's difficult to deny that
they did a Stella job the soundtrack is
amazing and they really bring the
glitzing glamour to life while not
shying away from how brutal some of the
killings were there's a lot to to be
learned from this as well and it works
expertly to show the hurt that Greek can
bring Sophia varara does a fantastic job
and I think she's completely
unrecognizable in the role have to say I
was surprised by how good this was and
if you're watching this without seeing
it then definitely check it out gisala
brought a plague to the streets of Miami
that in the end ruined hundreds of lives
still though made for a good TV show I
guess which yeah watch it if you like a
bit of crime really in doing my research
I found that a lot of the financial
structure of Miami was built off the
back of these kingpins bringing in
massive amounts of money this money was
then put into the banks who themselves
and worked as lenders to home buyers and
businesses therefore the city was able
to quickly rise up ironically down to
people like grisela Pablo Escobar even
works as an opening quot and whether
this is real or not is something we
don't know however we do know that
grisal that gave him advice early on and
this helped him to become the
established name he was it saw that they
went on to become Rivals but whether
that's the case is something we also
don't know either way that wraps up the
show I had a blast with it and I hope
you guys have enjoyed going back through
it make sure you leave your thoughts
below and a huge thank you for sting
through the video please drop a like and
if you want to support the channel as a
member of the spoiler side Squad then
please click the join button you'll get
early access to videos every week and it
goes such a long way to helping us out
going to get some heavy spoilers merch
we've also got our t-shirt line located
below the video that will let you pick
up all kinds of tops like our Theory
time ones house Dragon stuff Marvel te's
and more we drop new designs on there
all the time too so definit keep an eye
out and thank you if you've got one now
if you want some else to watch you've
got a breakdown on screen right now in
which we go over what we've heard about
stranger things 5 so LS of things to
talk about lots of different plot leaks
so definitely head over there right
after this by the way huge thank you for
sting through the video I've been your
host Paul you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care
peace